jacksepticeye beauty floor yang you
think you're gonna beat me this year in
the annual bottle flip challenge yes I'm
the reigning champ
I'm the back-to-back I get it rubbing it
in every single day I'm not gonna smack
my bow on my head this is the air i beat
you feel sure sure show me your bottle
what type of bottle you guys I picked my
big bottle okay I've got my Evian I like
a we both big flat I'll sit with them I
know this one just in case you decide
last year but I've been practicing okay
yeah sure you've been studying the blade
have been started studying the water
blade I know it all I got camera two
ready okay me to enjoy my feet I'm
sitting on the floor I can't get any
lower
okay the rule is simple we bottle flip
and whoever loses dies the loser has to
look at the ready fifty-fifty challenge
but though as punishment to learn to
better place you don't remember this it
was only a year ago and I already forgot
we do this every year
I know and the point still accumulate
okay but if I'm losing I will call for a
sudden bet that's very cuz you're the
reigning champion yeah we're not my
golden belt is taking up room in my
house I need to get rid of it anyway
oh I get your bell and you get my
tambourine is that the rules no my belt
yeah I get my frickin Bell I died give
me this Bell
hats are some generations yeah save me
that okay you want to go first no I
think the reigning champion goes first
okay cuz I'm gonna nail it first try I'm
just sayin okay
I told you don't do well under pressure
you got this you got this you don't
encourage me we're supposed to be more
you got this you got it that's
distracting shut up oh my god ease
performance anxiety
it's Java I don't I watch hike you they
always get it
what are they here what did they do to
get over it someone else hung up some
I'm talk about their past I'm not here
to cheer you on I'm your enemy
[Music]
okay that was a genuine reaction I don't
think you're that good of an actor oh
thank you that's true this is the
special quarantine episode yeah you can
snake out you be like I don't know if
you can do it I can hear that was good
there's no balance on that one I think
my bottle is cheating up new tactics
what is he learned out east and landed
on the tambourine good land flag oh it
has to line a flight god damn it I
didn't know that I lost the first one
whatever whatever
the bottle is long all right here we go
a Bob Ross painting Oh what am I looking
at it Bob Ross painting or a dekum yeah
decomposing corpse I saw Bob Ross
painting no it's not it's not I don't
believe you okay all right do whatever
you want okay I don't know what a
decomposing decomposing body looks like
embalming
shut up discombobulated yeah just watch
yourself in the mirror after you're done
with this challenge I can't do the
anxiety of you already beating it okay
all right knowing you take me just
yeah did you [ __ ] it up yeah get out I'm
two for two right now baby now you'll
miss a limb Pro I thought I had it down
okay come on sir yes damn it
thanks good Tamra why you just good
under pressure my turn here we go are
you listening I'm listening
that was a double cute finger puppets
cute finger puppets are praying mantis
eating a murder Hornet okay okay are you
looking away okay
click I can't see it it's you need to
click the spoiler tag Kosar tricky
watching I don't know nothing too bad
has happened yet my more in pain than
you are I'm not even looking it's worse
than my head oh my God he's just chewing
through his head oh yeah alright I've
lost the gift you lost it yet the bottle
flip dammit I lost it too dammit okay I
like that I like the tambourine rattling
the middle of it yeah that's how you
know if I failed the tempering will
rattle
okay oh it landed and then it fell over
damn oh my God we're so bad what's it
not good I know I barely even tried I
don't know what's wrong with me okay
good all right this is the one I feel it
I feel it okay all right land it's
amazing that is wobble what my bottle no
[Music]
no no no I don't know everyone's annoyed
with us right now okay a canoe that's
good oh did you get it I came that was
penned out of ten it is a ramble like
your stinking Bell oh I'm gonna have to
watch a man pulling out his nail or a
beautiful lake
three two one prepare for death oh
you're gonna have to click the thing
again okay damn it I don't want to watch
that I don't look at that I don't want
to see that yeah baby I'm safe another
Bob Rock huh yeah what do you keep
tricky but yeah another epic win for the
lads it's a beautiful lake very nice
char just me with energy for
I know I kiss it I smack it with
tambourine and here we go
no stop stop
sup there it's over it's over do it
anymore
what did you do angry did you smack the
bottle with the tambourine I poached the
tambourine oh it still works it's so
work okay you'll get some kick in it
just because your child breaks its leg
this to mean it's broken completely yes
true just I mean you saw them off you do
you have any tape I do not I got spit on
go go go chew them I'll repair it like
those Japanese do it with gold let's see
what you're saying is that you didn't
land that one what I'm saying jack is
two words miss I miss go see I'm not
there and perfectly hit you I can't get
my energy think you could have chose a
sturdier in stage bell how dare you tell
of tambourine ready for this seems like
father to me
okay Brown is in a jar or severed head
of a serial killer in a jar and potato
potatoes you know what I mean
yeah I want no one would fit brownies in
a jar this is definitely why did you put
brownies in a jar and now I see through
the tambourine the tambourines breaking
help me yeah you liar color psycho bed
I'm doing an executive decision yeah and
I'm changing bottle do the judges allow
it
the judges have spoken okay so just
allow Thank You judges
all right how about this we throw at the
same time it's never been done before
it's like a game
it's we're changing the game okay count
it down okay
three two one throw oh you said I was
and then I got pressures do you like it
do you like this I'd rather watch a man
cut clean of my arm oh that's not gonna
be another forest that's not a forest oh
you get all the easy ones yeah but what
is the score it's three two isn't it yes
I don't like that that's a bad score for
me it's a good score I'm doing it from
here this time that's how much of a
psychopath I am way okay now we look the
same
okay I'm not gonna be in a PewDiePie
video of these - oh it's good it's good
mine wasn't even close there wasn't even
my camera I'm really gonna have camera
two because I'm not capturing the bottle
at all sorry okay all right are you
ready jack ah house in the woods
the bells trying to save a stupid guy's
balls
what's I kind of want to see this okay
[Music]
playing he's freaking oh okay okay James
saw
[Music]
his balls are purple what that's not
even like oh yeah doctors are medical
instrument users no that's just
something you weld a car together okay
I'm sorry
goddamn it you don't weld with the Saab
or whatever I can't think my balls hurt
oh that's good that was good I nailed
mine did you nail yours yet - good - oh
that was close like a second could have
gone either way
alright beautiful mountains in
Madagascar virgin Ireland
oh I think so get all the severed heads
oh sure Jesus blesses and save his holy
God he looks like he came out of the bog
bury your face did somebody find it in
the bog and just pot it arose daddy
beside you
I could smell the potatoes are me chinga
Church in Marin we need to let a snake
score papa that's that's accurate but I
don't want my jingle czar chimra in air
[Music]
I'm getting good now you can't beat me
anymore
did you land that yeah burning victim
from a car crash or a guy running from
the police or the carrot please be carat
weight is that good or bad I don't know
all right sir it's a video yeah thank
God that could have been that could have
been gonna either of those phantom fuga
Carolyn fuga cardem fuga I'm switching
back to my chunky ball I was just giving
you a chance
it's just felt bad you gave me a lot of
chances but okay I'll take it I'll take
the last two years I've been giving you
a chance at name mm-hmm this year melt
the raw pheromones coming off of me in
person a Chad energy yeah those are I
artist shingles and nothing else
yes damn it
yes your beautiful picture of ocean or
nothing bad all right here we go it's
the ocean I could see the blur before
you unblurred it it was you can't see
through the blur damn it I lost my juice
six-four brown chocolate made from
Milken and a man who'd gonna read that
that's not where a hand goes oh thank
god its Milkha I can tell me the colors
before the bear oh my god Shh
damn it have you even gotten a bad one
yet I don't think so God the internet
loves you today oh this is my day
because today's bottle flip champion
belt belt
taking over Bruning set tambourine day
okay wait what is that the judges they
have spoken whatever you said
sudden death question that part of the
judges do not agree
oh okay I don't listen to broken judges
all right all right
this one has to be backwards you got to
throw it you gotta throw it this way you
gotta throw it behind you know
yeah great what definitely not even
close the feet to 100 yeah shut up okay
I am so close you better be sweating boy
you didn't land okay I didn't Hey that's
six five are you serious yep I brought
it back you judges man taking his first
step after foot operation man getting
foot to bat bye-bye
oh great no great at the foot bye bye
didn't I got the foot bye bye bye bye
bye bye I can't watch this please sack
and make it stop I'm sorry alright watch
my god his leg exploded this is all your
fault
okay well what's that the judges no no
there's no way the judges are saying
unless Jack wins the next point no Felix
wins Oh judges have spoken
wait no my judges says booking bro they
agreed I knew it you don't talk bad
against the judges I thought I knew my
bail but they're against me today so
they feel sorry for you they say they
say you stink Jack you know after this
were actually friends right no okay this
is it this is it
camera two
Oh God I didn't throw my baby Oh God
come on ball boy come on boy boy boy boy
you gave me advantage in possible
singing loud bang judges must have been
wrong a great new sunset a great view of
sunset this is not a great views is
great views us oh that is nice I didn't
even get a chance to look away you just
went for that punishment okay oh this is
the last chance this is the sudden-death
for real okay the judges have spoken
I you also said that last time if I
didn't win then I win the holding at
this point okay okay whatever scared boy
yeah shaking all right yeah all right
yes love you stink
you broke your tambourine for this how
does that feel tambourine of shades you
have to put it in and you can wear it as
a hat from now on how to shave I will
accept it it is my fate every for every
black
okay you got to do one last one it's got
to be a bad one
wait why cuz you just lost the whole
game so you got to do a really bad 5050
oh I forgot Africa delicious Mud Pie are
as this is it
man trapped in Utica oh my god I feel
terrible
no we can actually show this wait did it
fall down
no it's they just go through these tight
cracks and they get stuck it's the worst
ahh I can't do that I don't want to know
about that thank you terrible great
thank you real great start to my day
Felix Thanks
you may have won this round jack and the
last one but I will come back next year
even worse
where's it gonna be next year are we
going to international weather it could
be in Tokyo for all that that would be
epic
with the live audience this year we make
a variety show out of it next year I'd
like to thank the judges I'd like to
thank you camera to most of all I'd like
to thank you for losing again today any
any any final words for the translator
you played a good game
you were strong you flipped for her
point you came back when I least
expected it but you know I had a tough
year I dealt with I was came to doping
charges but next year I'm gonna come
back and I'm gonna be stronger than ever
bottle flip challenge 2021 Oh
[Music]
[Applause]